- [Voiceover] Oh look, it's my cousin Fal!
Cousin Fal, what can I do for you?
- [Voiceover] Hey Sal, what's up?
- [Voiceover] Oh, well not
much, I'm just sitting here
thinking about what
video I should do next.
- [Voiceover] Well then
maybe you can help me.
I'm starting a shape collection.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
how do you need help?
- [Voiceover] Well look
at these shapes over here!
I have no way to classify them!
- [Voiceover] Okay, well
there's a bunch of ways
that you could classify them.
The first way, you could think about
how many sides each of these shapes have,
so that's one way
to think about it,
how many sides they have.
- [Voiceover] How do I figure that out?
- [Voiceover] Okay, well
let's look at each of these
and think about how many sides they have.
So this first shape right over here
this is one side.
We see this kind of
straight right over here,
it's the straight line
between these two corners,
so that's one side.
Two sides, three sides,
and four sides.
So this shape right over
here has four sides.
- [Voiceover] Okay, I think I get it.
What about this shape right over here?
- [Voiceover] Okay,well let's see.
This one, well same idea,
this one also looks like it has one,
two, three,
and four.
Four sides.
- [Voiceover] What about this one?
- [Voiceover] Okay, well this one,
actually this is interesting.
This one actually had no corners,
and it has no sides,
there's no straight edges over here,
this thing is all curved.
So since it has no corners,
it also has no sides,
or at least the way that
I'm thinking about it.
So I would say that this one over here
has zero sides.
Let me write that a
little bit neater for you.
- [Voiceover] Okay yeah, I like
to write things really neat.
- [Voiceover] Okay, zero sides.
And it has zero corners.
Actually let me write
them for all of them.
This one has four sides,
and we could also count the corners.
We have one, that's
where the two sides meet.
One, two, three, four corners.
This shape over here,
it also has four sides,
we already counted that and it has
one, two, three, four corners.
So four sides and four
corners actually describes
both of these shapes,
this one has zero sides and zero corners--
- [Voiceover] What about the green one?
- [Voiceover] Okay, well let's just see.
One side, two sides,
three sides, and four sides,
and it also has one,
two, three, four corners.
So this is also four
sides and four corners
is also true of that one there.
- [Voiceover] Do all shapes have
four sides and four corners?
- [Voiceover] No no, not at all.
I mean this one right over here had
zero sides and zero corners,
and actually this last
shape right over here,
doesn't seem to have four
sides or four corners.
If we count them,
we have one side, two sides,
and three sides.
So this one has three sides,
and if we count the corners we have
one corner, two corners, and three,
and three corners.
- [Voiceover] Oh, thanks a
bunch Uncle-- Cousin Sal.
But I always get confused whether
you're my cousin or my uncle.
But I'll call you Cousin Sal.
But I read in a shape magazine
that there was other
ways that I can classify.
I can classify based on
whether the sides have the same size.
So which of these have all the sides
are the same size?
- [Voiceover] Okay, well calm down.
Let's look at this.
So if you look at this
one, it has four sides.
But we see, that this
side right over here,
this green side, is clearly shorter
than this purple side.
So all the four sides here
are not the same length.
But if we look at this
shape right over here,
this side at least looks like
the same length as this side.
And that looks like the
same length as this side,
and that looks like the
same length as that side.
So it looks over here like
all four sides are the same length.
And that's also true for this shape.
This side looks the same
length as that side,
looks the same length as that side,
looks the same length as that side.
That's also true for
this three-sided shape.
This side looks the same
length as that side,
This is the same length as that one.
- [Voiceover] Oh, thank
you so much Cousin Sal!
I'm ready to go classify
my shape collection.
This is awesome!
- [Voiceover] Well I'm
glad that I could help!